[Música]
hola soy maría clara calle por natalia
cabrera esto es aquí y américa el
programa donde revisaremos en
profundidad las historias y las noticias
de nuestro continente en esta edición
iremos a eeuu donde aumenta la atención
por las políticas migratorias el jefe
del departamento de seguridad nacional
asegura que hay una oleada de migrantes
que está en camino de ser la mayor en 20
años solo el mes pasado más de 100.000
personas intentaron cruzar la frontera
los republicanos responsabilizan a joe
biden por sus cambios normativos
mientras el congreso debate dos
proyectos que ayudarían a legalizar el
estatus de más de 11 millones de
migrantes en paraguay el gobierno de
mario abdo benítez sigue enfrentando una
dura presión social aunque la cámara de
diputados- hundió la moción para hacerle
un juicio político en las calles no
paran los clamores que piden su renuncia
por la gestión de la pandemia
el cob y 19 también golpea a la política
de brasil el presidente yair bolsonaro
nombró a un nuevo ministro de salud el
cuarto que llega en medio de la pandemia
solo que esta vez el país se enfrenta a
un repunte de muertes que no había visto
antes
[Música]
comencemos con la tensión en eeuu desde
que asumió la presidencia
joe biden le ha apostado a cambiar las
políticas migratorias y ahora esas
modificaciones se sienten especialmente
en la frontera con mexico la misma
administración reconoce que podrían
llegar más migrantes que en los últimos
20 años varios sectores aseguran que eso
se debe a que bardem permitió que los
menores de edad se quedaran en eeuu al
menos temporalmente los republicanos
critican esa decisión y en medio de la
tormenta política la casa blanca
respalda dos proyectos en el congreso
para proteger aún más a los migrantes
veámoslo en el siguiente reporte
muchos de la llaman la crisis fronteriza
de joe biden mientras el presidente
impulsa una serie de reformas sobre la
migración desde que llegó a la casa
blanca el mandatario para la
construcción del muro con méxico comenzó
a desmantelar el programa que obligaba a
los migrantes a quedarse en el
territorio azteca mientras eeuu decidía
caso por caso y recibió al menos
temporalmente a los menores de edad que
emigran solos esto contrasta con el
aumento de personas que han intentado
cruzar hacia la unión americana solo en
febrero las autoridades estadounidenses
detuvieron a más de 100.000 personas en
la frontera con méxico una cifra que no
se veía desde marzo de 2019 el
secretario de seguridad nacional estima
que si estos números siguen al ritmo
actual
eeuu tendría la mayor cantidad de
migrantes en los últimos 20 años
creo que mi lenguaje fue de hecho que
los números que estamos viendo podrían
ser los más grandes y si de hecho se
materializan como muestra la tendencia
podrían ser los números más grandes que
hemos visto en 20 años que este aumento
se evidencia especialmente con los niños
los lugares de acogida para menores en
eeuu están desbordados
casi nueve mil quinientos niños y niñas
no acompañados pidiendo asilo
todo esto desató las críticas desde el
lado republicano especialmente para que
bailen reconozca que hay una crisis
migratoria
aun nuestros agentes fronterizos están
abrumados y merecen la ayuda de su
gobierno federal hago un llamado a dejar
de lado la política trabajemos juntos
por la seguridad de nuestra nación el
gobierno se defiende diciendo que está
intentando revertir las políticas de
donald trump que califican como
violatorias de los derechos humanos en
la última administración nos dejó un
sistema desmantelado en france y cable
como cualquier otro problema vamos a
hacer todo lo posible para solucionarlo
pero esta postura no ha sido suficiente
para frenar la presión y ahora el
gobierno de bailén está entre la espada
y la pared pues mientras aumentan las
críticas por lo que ocurre en la
frontera sur la casa blanca respalda dos
proyectos de ley precisamente sobre
migración el congreso está dividido
sobre si dar o no la ciudadanía a 11
millones de migrantes incluyendo a los
conocidos gamers y extranjeros que
trabajan
la agricultura en eeuu
y ahora vamos a paraguay donde aumenta
la presión política
allí la causa del malestar es por el
manejo de la pandemia miles de
paraguayos han mantenido las protestas
en contra del gobierno de mario abdo
benítez y piden su renuncia por la falta
de suministros clínicos lo que comenzó
con manifestaciones de enfermeras
evolucionó a tal punto que la cámara de
diputados discutió una moción para
destituir al mandatario aunque
finalmente los legisladores rechazaron
la idea el descontento en las calles no
para y además el gobierno enfrenta el
peor momento de toda la pandemia esta es
la situación que enfrenta el presidente
paraguayo
a un ataúd con un mensaje contundente la
corrupción mata así protestan los
profesionales de la salud en paraguay
ante la falta de suministros clínicos
durante la pandemia
de hecho las protestas que forzaron la
salida de cuatro ministros comenzaron
con las voces de las enfermeras este
gremio salió a las calles a principios
de marzo y frente a la sede del
parlamento reclamaron más insumos para
combatir el kobe 19 como muchas
precariedades de repente de insumo sobre
todos tenemos insumos pero no lo
suficiente con los pacientes que
actualmente contamos porque tenemos más
de 120 actualmente se multiplican los
pacientes ahora mismo y estamos
trabajando muy intensamente la pregunta
reiterada en las calles es donde están
los 1.600 millones de dólares del
préstamo que el gobierno de mario abdo
benítez aprobó para combatir la pandemia
con otros responsables de las no gestión
administrativa
no tuvieron total y la historia le va a
pasar la cuenta ese malestar se propagó
por el país y desde el 5 de marzo no han
parado las manifestaciones contra el
gobierno paraguayo
aunque cada vez menos personas
participan en ellas las protestas
ejercieron la presión suficiente para
que varios partidos políticos llevaran
una idea del congreso destituir a mario
abdo benítez y a su vicepresidente hugo
velázquez
al final el oficialista partido colorado
salvó a los mandatarios de ir a un
juicio político al poner los 42 votos
que terminaron por hundir la moción en
la cámara de diputados pero el
descontento no para y los insumos están
más escasos que nunca ahora paraguay
atraviesa un repunte de los contagios
que ha alcanzado el récord de casi 3.000
casos positivos en un solo día y a las
afueras de los hospitales muchos
familiares piden donaciones para sus
pacientes
el sistema está saturado al borde del
colapso en donde estamos peleando para
salvaguardar la integridad y la vida de
nuestros compatriotas el gobierno
intenta hacerle frente a la situación
poniendo a disposición los hospitales
militares e imponiendo un nuevo toque de
queda nocturno pero la situación está
lejos de mejorar en paraguay
y ahora vamos a eeuu antes de revisar
más noticias de las américas esta semana
en una entrevista con el diseños un
periodista le preguntó a joe biden si
creía que el presidente ruso vladimir
putin era una asesina y el mandatario
respondió que si la frase desató la peor
crisis en las relaciones bilaterales que
ha habido en años rusia le ordenó a su
embajador en washington que volviera a
moscú y putin le replicó a vaivén
diciendo quien así llama así se llama
luego la casa blanca afirmó que baile no
se arrepentía de su declaración
la noticia de venezuela es por cuenta de
los nueves billetes que comenzaron a
circular aunque las denominaciones
alcanzan hasta los 500 mil bolívares la
hiperinflación que golpea al país es tal
que esa cantidad de dinero equivale a
tan solo 25 centavos de dólar los
venezolanos están a la espera de un
billete de un millón de bolívares
y en bolivia la justicia sigue siendo
protagonista en las disputas políticas
la ex presidenta interina jeanine áñez
estará cuatro meses en prisión de manera
preventiva hasta que se resuelva el caso
que tiene en su cota está acusada de
terrorismo por su actuación en torno a
la salida del poder de evo morales a
finales de 2020 pero cuando ella estuvo
en la presidencia los jueces ordenaron
el arresto del ex mandatario de
izquierda y de varios de sus
funcionarios esto ha abierto un debate
sobre si la justicia está o no
politizada
[Música]
la pandemia también impacta esta semana
a brasil el presidente yair bolsonaro
posesionó al cuarto ministro de salud
que ha tenido el país durante la crisis
sanitaria los tres funcionarios
anteriores salieron en medio de
polémicas y algunos tuvieron claras
diferencias con el mandatario frente a
su manejo del cob y 19m tras los cambios
no paran de asir superan sus propios
registros de muertes por el brote como
lo explicamos en el siguiente informe
una pandemia y cuatro ministros de salud
desde el comienzo el presidente ya ir
bolsonaro y sus políticas de negación de
la pandemia han chocado con funcionarios
que el mismo nombre
[Música]
su primer ministro de salud luis enrique
mande está defendió el distanciamiento
social a pesar de que el mandatario
rechazaba la idea por los efectos en la
economía
las diferencias escalaron hasta que
mande está fue despedido el 16 de abril
de 2020
el ministro de salud pidió y reforzó
junto con los gobernadores la necesidad
del aislamiento la distancia el
presidente de la república dijo
exactamente lo contrario demostró lo
contrario rompió esta cadena de forma
sistemática haciendo que mucha gente
dudar muchas vidas
en su reemplazo llegó nelson take
durante su fugaz papel como ministro de
salud él también se opuso a las posturas
de bolsonaro especialmente a las
recomendaciones del presidente de usar
cloroquina al mes de llegar a la cartera
el ministro renunció a abrir la vida
está hecha de decisiones y hoy elegirme
fue así como eduardo para suelo comenzó
a dirigir el ministerio de salud en mayo
de 2020 desde que asumió el cargo las
críticas se enfilaron contra bolsonaro
por haber posesionado a un general del
ejército sin experiencia en salud
pública justo en el peor momento de la
pandemia para suelo no sólo impulsó la
como su jefe sino que aceptó la
desautorización pública que el
presidente le hizo sobre su plan de
comprar 46 millones de vacunas a china
señores es así de simple uno manda y el
otro obedece pero nosotros nos tenemos
cariño
de poco sirvió su obediencia bolsonaro
decidió cambiarlo por marcello queiroga
el 16 de marzo el gobierno dice que todo
es para renovar las políticas del
ministerio de salud
los impactos de la muerte por kobe 19
los podremos reducir con dos puntos
principales primero con nuestras propias
políticas de distanciamiento social que
permita reducir la circulación del virus
segundo con una mejora en la capacidad
de asistencial de nuestros servicios
hospitalarios asistencia a los
hospitales el cuarto ministro de salud
de bolsonaro llega a la cartera en la
peor semana de la pandemia con más de
2.000 muertos a causa del virus casi
todos los días
y me despido con la imagen de la semana
que llega desde estados unidos la
primera nativa americana en liderar un
puesto ministerial en toda la historia
del país ella es de la cndh miembro de
la etnia pueblo de laguna y quien ahora
será la secretaria del interior desde
allí jugará un papel determinante en las
políticas de los recursos naturales y
las tierras tribales
esto es todo por hoy gracias por
acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí y
américa recuerden que pueden seguirme en
redes sociales en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas soy maría clara calle
por natalia cabrera continúen con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]